the warnings are few the signs are
suddenly the time goes into reverse a
thunderous roar fills their and then
it strikes
and when it is over nothing is what a
tsunami the word in Japanese means
harbour wave Japan has been hit by many
tsunamis in its history as a result of
its location it lies across the edges of
four tectonic plates where most
earthquakes the principal cause of
tsunamis are war when two tectonic
plates push together the resulting
earthquake sends an enormous burst of
energy up through the ocean displacing
enormous quantities of water a series of
waves expands in all directions in deep
water these waves travel fast up to five
hundred miles an hour but only reach a
height of a few feet a passing ship
might not even notice but as the waves
enter shallow waters friction with the
ocean floor lowers the wave speed and
raises their height until at landfall
they can engulf a 10-story building
unlike ordinary waves a tsunami wave
doesn't crest and break instead it
advances like a wall of water that
crashes over the coastline and
everything in its way reaching even as
far as a mind
inland more damage is caused when the
wave recedes dragging everything in it
back under water and most tsunamis have
multiple waves each arriving anywhere
from 10 to 60 minutes after the first
strike just when survivors think the
danger is over the deadliest tsunami
ever recorded occurred in December of
2004 an earthquake off the coast of
Indonesia triggered a tsunami that
surged across the Indian Ocean and
reached as far as the coast of Africa
whole sections of cities were destroyed
more than 200,000 people died
most had no way of being warned
5,000 miles away the Pacific Tsunami
Warning Center in Honolulu is on call 24
hours a day to prevent a similar tragedy
from happening in the United States
scientists monitor tremors and quakes
from around the globe if a quake big
enough to cause a tsunami occurs it is
their job to alert the coastlines in the
tsunamis path the advice is simple move
to higher ground wait for news that the
tsunami has passed and be ready to deal
with the ruins left in its wake